it goes without saying that the 2010's
were a revolutionary decade for movies
now though it's time to look to the
future and take a dive into the hottest
releases from the first year of the
2020s from franchise tent poles to
long-awaited sequels to gripping
original productions these are the
movies you can't miss in 2020 in 2018 a
quiet place took Hollywood by surprise
turning a modest 17 million dollar
budget around to pull in nearly 350
million dollars worldwide at the box
office it's also one of the most highly
acclaimed horror films in recent years
with Rotten Tomatoes granting it an
overwhelmingly fresh rating and calling
it a ruthlessly intelligent creature
feature that says original as it is
scary so it's no wonder Paramount
Pictures would want to capitalize with
the sequel and on March 20th 2020 a
quiet place to will hit theaters while
writer director John Krasinski is
confirmed for the sequel now it wasn't
always that way
in an interview with the ringers the big
picture podcast Krasinski said he
initially didn't want to have anything
to do with the second film but was
convinced by his producer to at least
jot down a few ideas
he explained after like three weeks he
was like why don't you just write this
and then we'll get another filmmaker and
of course Jedi Mind tricked me into
signing on to the sequel as far as the
story goes writer scott beck and brian
woods have told Fandango that there is
the potential to focus on new families
Krasinski also seemed to agree that the
sequel wouldn't be just about the
abbot's of the original telling The
Hollywood Reporter in our circumstance
to think that the audience loved most
was the world that's the cool thing that
you could explore on and on on May first
2020 Marvel Studios is set to release
Black Widow its 24th MCU film in the
beginning of the Marvel Universe's
fourth phase during the Marvel Hall H
panel at 2019 San Diego comic-con the
cast and crew of Black Widow discussed
the film's official announcement along
with a few story and character details
chronologically Black Widow will take
place between Captain America's Civil
War and Avengers infinity war as far as
plot goes specific details are still
being kept under wraps but according to
its cast the film is going to be
something of a departure from other
Marvel properties
David Harbor who plays Alexi otherwise
known as the Red Guardian spoke with
Marvel after the panel he said it feels
like an espionage movie it's got all
these elements to it
Scarlett Johansson also said it's a
little dirty it's a little salty it's
bringing some realness to the Marvel
Universe joining Johansson and harbor
are
Florence pew as Yelena Natasha's fellow
Black Widow agents OT Fagin Leia's Mason
a fixer who apparently has a complex
relationship with Natasha and Rachel
vice as Molina a character who's
previously been through the widow
program five times long live the Kiana
sense thanks in no small part to the
ongoing success of the John wick series
rumors have been bouncing around
Hollywood about potential sequels and
reboots for everything from the matrix
to speed one follow-up that's definitely
coming however is Bill and Ted face to
music a fantastic voyage following in
the radical footsteps of 1989's
excellent adventure and 1991's bogus
journey after many years of rumblings
Keanu Reeves and Alex winter officially
confirmed in March of 2019 that strange
things were indeed afoot at the circle-k
once more william sadler is slated to
reprise his role as the oft Melvin's
Grim Reaper while original writers Chris
Matheson and ed Solomon have returned to
penned the screenplay and Galaxy Quest
director Dean Paris o is set to helm
Reeves himself revealed that the plot
will catch up with the now middle-aged
bill S Preston and Theodore Logan as
they realize that adult responsibilities
like fatherhood have prevented them from
coming up with that universe savings
song they were destined to write bill
and Ted face the music will be partying
on in production throughout 2019 and is
set for release on August 21st 2020
author Owen colfer once described his
young adult fantasy series Artemis Fowl
as die hard with faeries critics
meanwhile have caught Artemis the new
Harry Potter
if those comparisons piqued your
interests good news eight novels about
this young criminal masterminds
coming-of-age were published between
2001 and 2012 for your reading pleasure
or you could just wait until May 29th
2020 when a film adaptation of the first
book in Cofer series is slated to hit
theaters that first book finds the 12
year old antihero kidnapping a fairy in
the hopes of restoring his family
fortune and finding his long-lost father
the Disney produced feature stars Irish
newcomer for Dia Shaw as Artemis with
the supporting cast that includes Judi
Dench Josh GAD and Game of Thrones Nonso
Anozie a Kenneth Branagh best known for
Marvel's first Thor film and a multitude
of Shakespeare adaptations is in the
director's chair a rolly previously
filled for Disney on 2015 Cinderella
let's be fair it's probably ambitious to
talk about the New Mutants as a 2020
release at
this rate assigning an actual date to
the seemingly cursed x-men project is
like waiting for a toad to get struck by
lightning you know what happens to a
toad when it's struck by lightning after
an initial trailer was released in the
bygone days of October 2017 the New
Mutants has been pushed back no fewer
than three times shifting from April
2018 to February 2019
then to August 2019 the recent release
of Disney's post Foxx mergers schedule
however revealed that New Mutants had
been delayed yet again all the way to
April 3rd 2020 so what's behind the
delays by all accounts it's not actually
the quality of the film itself unlike
Dark Phoenix New Mutants has reportedly
been well received in test screenings
the movie source Comics created in the
1980s by Chris Claremont and Bill
syncovich remained unique fan favorites
too the cast features up-and-comers like
The Witches annua Taylor joy and Game of
Thrones Maisie Williams sadly a number
of factors have been at play in
frustrating the movie's release the
release of Deadpool 2 a decision to play
up the movies horror elements expansion
of certain characters roles and the
earth-shaking Disney Fox merger among
them bad Deadpool with any luck fans
will actually be able to watch the New
Mutants in 2020 and hopefully it will
live up to its potential as a stylish
and frightening final x-men movie from
Fox currently very little is known about
Christopher Nolan's upcoming action epic
Tennant's which is slated for release on
July 17th 2020 we do know that it
revolves around the world of
international espionage and that is
shaping up to be an expensive production
with the budget reportedly clocking in
at about 225 million dollars on top of
that Tennant will be shown in IMAX so
expect big things literally the film
stars John David Washington Aaron
taylor-johnson and Robert Pattinson
among others Pattinson told USA Today in
April 2019 that he had been sworn to
secrecy regarding Tennant's details the
actor was fond of the script however and
said that Nolan has changed his mind
about doing big-budget movies Pattinson
explained there's just something about
Chris Nolan's stuff he seems like the
only director now who can do what is
essentially a very personal independent
movie that has huge scale I read the
script and it's unreal Pixar's newest
movie onward is set in a fantasy
suburbia and follows two elf brothers
voiced by Tom Holland and Chris Pratt as
they set out into the world in search of
magic that will allow them to spend a
day with their dead father
word is a completely new entry to the
Pixar cannons so it's imaginative world
promises to be like nothing the studio
has done before and judging by the
film's first teaser trailer which
features all kinds of magical creatures
there will be more than enough for
fantasy fans to sink their teeth into
onward is directed by Dan Scanlon who
helm 2013's monsters University and has
worked on the senior creative team for
brave Inside Out cocoa and Toy Story 4
this is a personal project for him too
he told the audience at d23 that the
story was inspired by his own personal
search for answers regarding his father
who passed away when he was just a year
old Pixar's onward hits theaters on
March 6 2020 in addition to the rest of
the MCU phase four projects Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige took to
the stage at 2019 San Diego Comic Con to
announce Eternals which will make its
way to theaters on November 6 2020 while
little is known regarding the plot of
Eternals the film will be based on the
cosmic Jack Kirby characters first
introduced in the pages of Marvel Comics
in 1976
according to Marvel the Eternals are a
race of godlike beings locked in a
millennium old conflict with the less
evolved deviants and their originators
the Celestials they are immortals
blessed to a strange sometimes monstrous
powers there's a little bee coming out
of me right now
Eternals boasts an all-star cast
including Angelina Jolie Richard Madden
Kumail Nanjiani and Salma Hayek it's
directed by Chloe sow whose two previous
films 2015's songs my brother taught me
and 2017 s the rider were both met with
critical acclaim with the rider being
nominated for Independent Spirit Awards
for Best Film and Best Director the call
of the wild Jack London's 1903 adventure
novel about a sled dogs journey across
the Yukon Territory as a literary
classic just look at how many times has
been adapted to the screen stretching
all the way back to the silent era in
the past the lead human role of
prospector John Thornton has been played
by Hollywood tough guys like Clark Gable
Charlton Heston and Rutger Hauer on
February 21st 2020 however John
Thornton's rugged boots will be filled
by Harrison Ford in a live action
animation hybrid from lilo and stitch
and How to Train Your Dragon director
Chris Sanders and Logan writer Michael
Greene the impressive supporting cast is
rounded out by Dan Stevens Karen Gillan
Omar sy and Bradley Whitford he remains
to be seen just how Sanders animation
expertise will bring the story's animal
characters to life in this 20th Century
Fox production but the impressive
pedigree of the
material makes this adaptation one to
keep an eye on after years in
development the big-screen adaptation of
Naughty Dog's video game franchise
Uncharted will finally be making it to
theaters on December 18th 2020 in 2017
it was announced as spider-man's Tom
Holland would be taking on the lead role
of Nathan Drake in Sony's prequel film
which will star the same lead character
from the game but won't be following its
plots instead it will introduce a
younger version of Drake as he learns
the tricks of the trade from his mentor
Sully Bryan Cranston is also rumored to
star but his role remains unknown at the
time of publication Uncharted has run
through a series of directors over the
course of its development with Seth
Gordon David O'Russell Neil burger and
Shawn Levy all having been attached at
some points finally in January 2019
variety announced 10 Cloverfield Lane
Stan Trachtenberg would take the reins
currently little else is known about the
film but if the casting rumors are true
the combination of Holland and Cranston
could make for one video game adaptation
that can't be missed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]